what's going on guys this is the top
five brilliant moves from richard report
you know you got the candidates coming
up so we gotta check the best fives the
top brilliant moves from some of the
players right we got richard rapport
here now of course this is uh nils
grandilius with the white pieces versus
richard report so we're in the first one
here it's black to move what do you do
in this position right so it's black to
move right now let's take a stock of the
position and kind of look at what's
going on you can pause the video if you
need to but you got to figure this one
out what did richard report play in this
position against neil's grand dealers
with the black pieces let's see let's
see what's going on pause the video if
you need to of course so queen um is
attacking the queen here we could
capture it could be a queen trade right
we do want to look at checks and
captures and threats we can threaten
mate but he's just going to take us
right he's going to capture us maybe
rook takes b3 that doesn't look good
pawn takes or knight takes okay
right i mean rook takes f7 he's on our
seventh rank what do you do here what do
you do
sometimes one of the best ways to make
things happen in the game is to look at
moves that you did not consider the
crazy moves like this one right here
look h1 oh my goodness
rick h1 and he's done that is a move
right there big fella from a big fella
that's disgusting after queen takes
queen that's me rook takes d1 and he's
done that's mate right there that's
beautiful so of course that doesn't
happen so after rook h1 well okay what's
the possibility what if i just take the
rook come on now well queen c3 gg start
a new one that's me right there there's
no way to stop this checkmate oh you
know what there is the computer way
okay so king takes and then we're going
to check mate here on b2 right but um
that's made as well so what happened is
nils plays rook to g1 and says ah very
clever
very clever that was cool and then
he just takes the rook
and you can cue the the failed noises
everywhere
this is over right queen takes g1 and
queen c3 and black wins the game's over
that was brilliant right here that rook
h1 how beautiful was that from um from
rapport here finding rook h1 against
nils here this was number one top five
brilliant move let's move on to number
two okay guys here we are with number
two this one is loic van welli versus
richard report okay black pieces here
let's take stock what's going on first
off queen hanging your queen is hanging
pause this video if you need to look at
the whole board and then come up with a
move or two or combination whatever you
have but it's black to move what do you
do
let's take stock right queen's hanging
king looking kind of crazy his king's
not we have an open rook file but i mean
not really much is going on there right
now right because our queen is hanging
like the queen's hanging so we have to
deal with this right well how do you
deal with it what do you do
here's the move here in fact richard
report says my queen hanging so when my
queen is hanging well the logic behind
when my queen is hanging is
to sack it sacrifice the queen that's
the right logic says richard report rook
takes h2 sacrifice it
so after rook takes h2 wow what happens
well let's see what happens after queen
takes queen after queen takes rook takes
g2 and what do you do king f1 you can't
go too obvious right you're in check and
you have to move the king and then we
have rook to h6 mate what a checkmate
queen sacrifice mate okay not made just
yet bishop h4 but that's going to be
easy rook takes h4 for the score that's
made right that's beautiful absolutely
stunning what a sacrifice work takes h2
nasty move right well okay okay cool
that's cute right all right i can't take
your queen all right cool cool what
happens if i take the rook then right
but if i take the rook boom if i take
the rook well then queen takes f2 now in
fact after rook takes h2 games already
over rezzy on the spot resignation right
this is game over rook takes h2 but we
just want to kind of see what happens
right if king takes h2 you have two
choices rook check but i mean he just
goes back and you just don't want to
deal with that right queen takes f2 is
just the best move threatening rook h6
and mate also threatening queen g2 mate
a double mate threat here in fact queen
takes e3 probably one of your best moves
which is still gonna lead to mate anyway
well that was pretty cool this was
number two let's move on to number three
okay guys here we are number three this
one is richer report versus danielle de
verney so okay richard reports playing
white here what do you do in this
position again we take stock we observe
what is going on well let's take a look
here back paul's video once again if you
need to
let's let's see what's going on it's
white to move okay my queen is actually
x-raying the king if i move this pawn my
queen is absolutely hanging so f6 pawn
takes i mean that's scary because my
queen is straight up hanging i do have a
pawn over here maybe i could push it i
have the two bishops you just want to
take stock what's going on right before
you start calculating you got to see
what do you have i got two bishops can't
be down anything right we have two
brooks kings in the corner i mean it's
like double edged for real here in fact
black might be even playing for more
right one two three four five okay we
got five pieces one two three four five
we got the two bishops but they're kind
of tucking i mean we're on his king but
our queen is kind of pinned this is a
nuts position this requires a lot of
precision and calculation but of course
that's up for you to do right now it is
why to move you're playing richard
report what do you do
playing as ritual report in fact so
that's what you're playing as right here
right to move the move is
well if i'm dealing
with some queen issues like we've seen
before right what was the saying right
if we have some queen issues right we
sacrificed the queen what else did you
think we were gonna do here sacrifice
the queen absolutely we didn't even
think about the next move right queen
takes g4 right now of course after f
takes g6 the game's over resigns but
let's see what happens after queen takes
g4 you play eight seven right eight
seven clap it up for you if you say
eight seven garbage it's not a move at
all that is not a move h7 does not work
you actually are done for right h7 i
just move out of the way and have a nice
day really probably kj but this doesn't
work the idea here was after sacrificing
the queen is i'm gonna get it right back
oh
my goodness are you serious yes i am
very serious after the king moves then
i'm going to take this and i get a queen
and you don't have any logical checks
here queen takes g2
come on right that's not going to happen
and then we have this right this
pressure here what a queen sacrifice f
takes g6 is winning on the spot followed
by this obviously and we have the x-ray
and your q is hanging after i mean
obviously you have to take mine so this
was an awesome move that was sweet that
was number three let's move on to number
four
here we are with number four a real real
real spicy one okay we got john kristoff
duda
versus richard reporter with the black
pieces okay cool look at this position
first off what's going on well duda is
bought the mate
okay he's going to checkmate richard
report in a moment's notice this is
critical
very critical right now very critical by
the way this is not checkmate so you
know a spongebob fail noise right for
you guys that you know got hit here oh
it's made one not at all actually
absolutely not not mate here the queen
is defending so if you thought that
that's okay you're gonna be just fine we
love you okay queen h4 is defending that
queen h8 is checkmate we have to deal
with this is black so do we run with the
king do we need some love but we
probably still getting made it after
queen h a rook g8 check into oblivion
there king g7 is still going to be made
there we're running out of ideas we
don't have any good checks rook h4 and
queen h4 and queen g3 are not good
checks this is i mean like this don't
work so what do you do well that's up to
you to figure out black to move
here it is richard report played this
move right here he says well you know
what i remember right sack to queen huh
this is not a psycho queen one guys this
is not a queen sacrifice one but in fact
it is sacrificed something and that
something is the rook
you better look because
uh you're in trouble if you take this
rook yeah they're lying okay rook ca
there it is rookie aidan we great big
boy move there oh my goodness rook c8
look at this move i mean the the caliber
of strength of this move is just next
level guys not only does it block the
checkmate right i've dealt with
checkmate number two is now okay well
what's
uh i'm attacking the queen like why is
it so big well it's attacking the queen
it can it can be captured by two pieces
the queen and the rook let's see what
happens right now of course if rook if
queen takes c8 there's an obvious bishop
e6 i mean come on now
come on now
right you got to give up the queen so he
takes with the rogue
rook takes ca
bishop e6 anyway this is almost
checkmate
white has g4 right now we're going to
attack the king paul takes g4 there is
still mate so everything needs to be
fast it needs to be accurate it needs to
be now right because if you do anything
that is not check well you get mated so
f takes g4 f takes g or h6 g4 f takes g4
with check and then here it is boom
queen takes e3 that's with check and the
king is like you know instead of going
back here i'm very exposed he just
decided to run up the board oh you know
when i'm out of the way have a nice day
right i mean plus there's like all kind
of stuff probably losing in game two
after bishop takes there's a lot that
can go on but after king h4
donna you can also check and take two as
well but kh4 the move here actually wins
on the spot air is queen f2 you're like
what queen f2 how does this win isn't
this just a draw well in fact you're
gonna draw nothing here if king g5 so
here there's a nice sequence let's see
if you can find it pause the video if
you need to spot it what do you do here
with black now
what do you do with black now the king
is on g5 you still have the may threat
available it's right here what do we do
in fact simple move here is actually
just taking the room literally you're
just up a row engine gives best move for
white is queen f6
right queen f6
because it stops the move what's the
intention after queen takes f6 is mate
go ahead take a look at it go ahead go
ahead i know go ahead look at it
it's me it's check me i know right it's
just amazing it's checkmate right it's
mate it's a strange one but it's made
queen is defending the may covering all
the squares everything's covered
absolutely brilliant stuff here from
report
absolutely brilliant right and after
queen f2 there was a resignation queen
f2 and uh do the resigns here so this
was number four now let's move on to the
final brilliant move from richard
rapport
okay guys here we are with number five
this one is richard report versus peter
svidler so you know always they've gone
just playing strong strong players right
peter's fiddler is no different super
super strong it's right to move what do
you do crazy position looks like
something was just captured right and
you're like oh yeah the bishops hanging
but you do want to look at king safety
where's your king what's going on with
this king where the pieces how's
development look there's questions you
need to answer here right so what do we
do why to move let's uh think about this
pause the video again if you need to
what do we do
okay so a big thing is in tactics all
the time but also in just chess period
is being aggressive but also looking for
moves that threaten things and attack
now of course i can just capture the
bishop but if you thought rook f4 great
job you found the right move but you
have to find the right follow-up rook f4
is attacking the queen nice move here
the queen needs to actually defend the
rook because if you move anywhere else
queen g5 queen h4 obviously is stupid
too but queen g5 leads to mate on the
move by taking rook takes fa or queen
takes f8 is going to lead to mate
immediately so queen to d8 logical move
says trade everything off i'm cool with
that says black says fiddler here but
richard report had other intentions here
it is white to move chat can you find it
if you're watching this from youtube
right now can you find this
move why to move it is not the move that
you are thinking
what is it
here's the move here if you found this
move oh yeah
oh you ready oh you're definitely ready
bishop takes d7 oh my goodness
whoa you can feel the shock wave through
the earth after bishop takes d7 what a
move what on earth is this how does this
even work
can he just take it yeah he can take
many things actually in fact after
bishop takes d7 the game ends on the
spot right here game's over no more pgn
but what i'm saying here is after bishop
takes d7 right what happens here let's
just look at a few things if knight
takes d7 right queen takes e6 right you
can't go up so rick f7 is going to be
made beautiful gross so okay let's move
this move this around if queen takes
queen takes f8 we already saw that so
that's a diversion obviously we also
just took a pawn with the bishops are we
capturing on e6 well what else is
available after knight takes d7 or queen
takes we looked at those well we have
this row takes f4 maybe we can bail out
how you thought you were bishop takes e6
i'm gonna take the whole house it said
everything must go sale everything got
to go after check rook f7 we're gonna
hit him right here splitting that's made
everything's done that's game over gross
move bishop d7 game ending move on the
spot wouldn't move there and richard
report was able to find it here against
peters fiddler this was the top five
brilliant moves from richard report
hopefully you enjoyed this one this
video here if you did then make sure you
guys watch the videos of course right
above me after this video so we'll see
you guys on the next video